oui et non parce que ce actionnée par un
oui avec des mesures bien précises alors
j'attendais le maire de valence parler
de sanctions effectivement mettre en
réserve l'argent qu'on donne parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d enfants sur le sien pour
pour aider les familles les mettre en
réserve et convoquer les parents pour
être entendue ça c'est une chose
importante parce que bien souvent les
parents ne se déplace pas lorsque les
eaux se commettent des méfaits et 2e
deuxième élément c'est pour ça que je me
suis mitigé dans mes propos c'est les
familles monoparentales
kelly connaît bien le sujet aussi c'est
plus de 5000 familles c'est-à-dire des
mamans qui sont seuls qui ne peuvent pas
et ne peuvent plus assumer de prendre en
charge leurs enfants parce que voilà la
société comme ça là c'est un vrai sujet
est ce qu'on leur enlève l'argent je me
suis fondu répondra peut-être sur ce sur
ce point bien précis
est ce qu'on aura lève ses moyens pour
faire vivre sa famille ou est-ce que
tout simplement on les laisse on les
soutiennent et il ya des moyens de les
aider puisque je vous répète moins cher
eric naulleau que le ministère de
l'intérieur à travers le cicr a mis en
place un plan stratégique national sur
la prévention de la dengue à ce monsieur
monsieur chenu doit connaître il ya de
très belles mesures qui sont qui devrait
être mise en place et surtout pour venir
en aide aux familles c'est un véritable
sujet si on s'attaque pas à la cellule
familiale
on ne trouvera jamais aucune solution
pourra mettre dix mille policiers en
plus on pourra faire tout ce qu'on veut
on n'arrivera jamais à trouver la
solution et je connais un peu le sujet
vous savez ça fait juste 30 ans c'est
pour ça que je commençais par vous alors
il faut pas être bien précis une loi qui
était un temps en vigueur qui ne l'est
plus qu avait été porté par eric ciotti
et qui disait ceci est puni de deux ans
d'emprisonnement et de 30000 euros
d'amendé le fait par le père ou la mère
de laisser son enfant mineur lorsque
celui-ci a été poursuivi ou condamné
pour une infraction violer les
interdictions et les obligations
auxquelles il est soumis et vous
sébastien chenu vous croyez à la
sanction
justement si vous me permettez eric
naulleau notre débat va paraître désuet
par rapport au débat qui était celui
précédente mais je voulais quand même le
dire parce qu'on va pouvoir peut-être
nous mais c'est vrai qu'après le
témoignage que nous avons et qui était
poignant moi je voulais le dire de quoi
parle-t-on on parle aujourd'hui d'une
violence c'est votre reportage l'a très
bien démontré une violence chez les
mineures qui explosent alors est ce que
c'est une sorte d' américanisation de la
société l'importation d'une société
violente
est-ce que c'est culturel on peut avoir
beaucoup d'explications mais il trouve
que c'est une réalité une majorité dans
les mineures dans l'est dans les faits
qui sont concernées il y a une majorité
de mineurs c'est ce que rappelait
d'ailleurs le ministre l'intérieur
moi je crois qu'il faut créer un
électrochoc aujourd'hui on peut
expliquer chaque situation toutes les
situations du monde s'explique on peut
effectivement être une mère de famille
monoparentale on peut être très pauvres
on peut avoir des difficultés face à un
enfant qui fermait 2,85 et qui fait la
loi chez soi en revanche il n'y a pas de
déterminisme
il ya aussi des gens très pauvres et moi
je suis député d'une circonscription
très pauvres qui élève très correctement
leurs gamins il est aussi des mères
seules qui élèvent très correctement
leurs gamins qui ne laisse pas de or à
l'heure à laquelle nous tenons nous nos
débats ici donc je pense qu'il faut
créer un électrochoc parce que celle
affaire de tous
ou alors il ya une jeunesse une partie
de la jeunesse pas toute la jeunesse une
jeunesse qui est extraordinaire dans ce
pays mais une partie de la jeunesse qui
va aller sur ce chemin qui est celui qui
se construit finalement dans la rue sans
repères je voudrais que il ya une
ambiguïté
tout le monde est d'accord sur le
phénomène grandissant de la violence on
en a discuté ici même avec des
délinquants de plus en plus jeune et
plus en plus violents mais c'est pas
l'objet de débats l'objet de débat c'est
est ce que bien sûr sanctionnant les
parias cela changer cette situation bien
sûr pas beaucoup dans la voyais autour
de cette annonce ont pas bien sûr bien
sûr je pense que d'abord lorsque vous
élever un enfant et que vous êtes aidés
pour cela
c'est le cas de beaucoup de familles qui
sont aidés aussi dans leur vie
quotidienne
vous avez des droits vous avez aussi des
devoirs si l'état vous épaulent dans
votre quotidien parce que vous n'y
arrivez pas vous avez en regard la
nécessité de porter une attention sur
votre enfant et si vous ne faites pas
par négligence ou par complicité toutes
les situations existent dans notre pays
on connaît des parents recéleurs on
connaît des parents qui ferme les yeux
on connaît des parents négligents
on connaît des parents extraordinaire
mais si vous ne le faites pas si vous
n'assumez pas cette fonction alors oui
vous devez être sanctionné la sanction
d'ailleurs n'est pas que financière on
parle toujours évidemment des
allocations familiales
bien sûr et d'ailleurs les allocations
familiales on peut les supprimer
totalement partiellement uniquement
confirmant le cas de l'enfant
délinquants de façon provisoire de façon
définitive une graduation et c'est je
pense aussi ce qui manque souvent mais
il peut y avoir d'autres formes de
sanctions
la déchéance de l'autorité parentale
c'est très fort mais je pense que pour
un parent qui ne s'en sort pas qui ferme
les yeux sur la délinquance de ces
enfants qui refusent d'assumer sa
mission de parents quand on les parents
on a des devoirs et des responsabilités
qui ne s'en sort pas il peut y avoir
autre chose que simplement effectivement
des conséquences financières
on peut sanctionner autrement que
financièrement mais je pense que la
sanction financière
aujourd'hui elle doit être tentés on n'a
jamais essayé on va examiner toutes les
formes de sanctions monsieur traoré vous
vous répondez non et je vais vous poser
une question à ce direct brut un ps que
vous nous aviez ce comportement de
jeunes délinquants
ça aurait changé quelque chose à votre
trajectoire que vos parents soient
sanctionnés ah bah non métaux du tout
personnellement serait inchangée savait
déjà à l'époque moi car j'étais dans la
gta jeunes délinquants mineurs
forcément j'étais d un peu conscients
mais j'aimais chercher quelque part et
j'avais le désir de réussir je voyais
mes copains autour de moi des camarades
savez dans les quartiers c'est compliqué
socialement c'est compliqué et aussi il
ya tourne à tous un rôle à jouer danser
dans ces problèmes là ne faut pas dire
va sanctionner des parents ça sera une
des solutions je pense qu'il doit
chercher une solution ailleurs vous
savez aujourd'hui des parents à l'époque
moi mes parents je peux me permettre
à l'époque il n'avait pas les quick est
aujourd'hui que les parents
d'aujourd'hui sont aujourd'hui mes
parents à l'époque mes parents ne
faisait pas m'aider voir et mam n'est
pas au sport voyez ce que je veux dire
j'étais livré à moi-même et on a une on
est dans une société où il ya des
devoirs non faits douala l'école quand
regarder le temps on passe beaucoup plus
de temps dehors qu'avec nos familles
personnellement tu vas aimer les soirs
chez toi aujourd'hui avec le monde qui
nous entoure
c'est à dire et l'heure de
l'informatique l'armee l'information à
la femme des informations aujourd'hui il
ya des enfants qu'ils arrivent le
reportage on prend connaissance des
réseaux sociaux comme les jeunes parents
qu'ils ont 35 ans trente trois ans on
peut le dire ils sont encore à jour mais
venir dire on va sanctionner les parents
pour moi c'est pas c'est pas une bonne
idée plutôt trouver d autres
alternatives
un enfant qui fait du mal ce qui va mal
faut s'aider lui parler c'est de
comprendre d'être à son écoute
est ce que vous dites des enfants livrés
à eux mêmes est ce que justement
sanctionner les parents les
responsabiliser c'est pas leur envoyer
le message qu'il faut pas que leurs
enfants soient livrés à eux-mêmes
précisément c'est chercher un coupable
des forces pour moi pour ma part c'est
chercher un coupable des forces
absolument aujourd'hui il doit avoir
deux éducateurs l'état la république et
les lois aujourd'hui si vous savez qu'en
france c'est interdit de gifler un
enfant mais portait en fait c'est un
enfant nous envoyer et l'avons dit
d'être polis et derrière mon affaire
choses qui vont attaquer par an je veux
le meilleur pour l'enfant pour mon
enfant comme tout chacun de nous on veut
le meilleur pour nos enfants permettant
à terme également définir s'il vous
plaît on était de finir et on veut tous
le meilleur pour nos parents pour nos
enfants et où tous les murs pour nos
enfants et au delà de ça devenu punir
les parents pour moi non plus à trouver
d autres alternatives accompagnés des
parents les tailles pour 50% les paroles
prendre 5 1%
c'est pas venir chercher un coupable
absolument non elle permettait de la
chesnaie ensuite elle vient me dit il ya
plusieurs choses agréables je suis pas
en accord
d'abord vous dit effectivement quand on
est d'enfer par une situation c'est
difficile bien sûr tout le monde le sait
mais il ya aussi des gens qui sont dans
des situations difficiles
je redis vous moi je suis député d'une
circonscription qui est la plus pauvre
l'une des plus pauvres de france si ce
n'est la plus pauvre andorre la région
parisienne et des gens qui ont des
difficultés sociales de travail d'emploi
de santé
j'en connais beaucoup et ils élèvent
pourtant fort honorablement leur enfant
il assume ce rôle d'éducateur vous dit
le rôle d'éducateurs il doit être
confiée à l'état aux enseignants à
l'école mais pas seulement
moi je suis désolé par oddo et partage
et non pas menons pas forcément monsieur
une obligation de résultat mais une
obligation de moyens au moins ils ont au
moins l'obligation de mettre leurs
enfants sur un chemin qu'on appelle ou
qu'on appelait encore un peu pardonnez
l'expression le droit chemin
oui je pense que les parents ils ont une
obligation de moyens et quand il
n'assume pas cette obligation moyens
quand il mentionne dans le sens donnent
pas la peine
quand ils refusent de l'assumer quand
ils sont défaillants alors on peut
tenter de différentes façons de pouvoir
leur envoyer un signe comme un
électrochoc qui veut dire monsieur le
maire il faut vous mettre en charge
d'être responsable tout le monde
s'exprime réponse de monsieur travailler
ensuite à bientôt promettez moi non
c'est une fausse idée sais c'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut voir les choses moi
j'évite d'aller cacher j'ai eu
j'y suis encore ça fait des années j'ai
voyagé gcc quoique marche
vous savez je connais la bêtise avec
nous c'est un explique expérience be
je ne suis pas fier de mon passé
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas du tout fier
c'est d'expérience bidon qui aujourd'hui
tu me fais connaître ces couacs et le
mal et c'est aujourd'hui encore vous
n'allez pas dire électrochoc des propos
comme ça pour nom les parents ils
veulent toujours le meilleur pour leurs
enfants
le fait que les gens ils travaillaient
de l'île loi de causalité faut aussi
être comme ça la loi de causalité on est
dans une société où tout change tout
change absolument
on peut pas dire appliquer c'est la fin
on va sanctionner l exposition trouver
un coupable pour moi ça c'est hors du
gym à trouver des coupables monsieur
mais d'abord je vous invite à être un
peu un monsieur vous nous dites j'ai un
passé j'en suis pas très fier mais au dj
set qui marche oui je pense qu'il faut
être humble parce que si vous savez ce
qui marche venez venez faire la
politique immédiatement parce que je
vous assure que je n'eus j'ai mis toutes
les sections qui n'a gardé v6 à gas au
groupe sauf dans le cas évident où le ou
les parents sont reconnus complice
avérée des actes délictueux de leurs
enfants évidemment sauf si après enquête
judiciaire
il est montré que règne au sein du foyer
la cellule familiale une violence inouïe
qui est donc encourager là effectivement
il faut sanctionner ses parents après
pour rebondir sur les cas qui font
l'actualité récemment donc ils sont des
cas de violence incroyable dans la rue
père prêter perpétrés par des jeunes
pour la grande majorité mineures je
pense malheureusement que la plupart des
parents qui se retrouvent dans ce cas là
qui est d'être devant les infos devant
les réseaux sociaux et voir ses vidéos
tournées qui implique leurs propres
enfants
je pense malheureusement que la plupart
sont complètement démunis est ce qui est
à mon sens dangereux est grave c'est le
sentiment d'impunité qui règne au près
de cette jeunesse qui se pensent
peut-être n'ont pas tous permis mais
qu'ils pensent à l'abri des lois parce
que ce qu'il faudrait sanctionner plus
durement
c'est le jeune ce qu'il faudrait
renforcer plus durement c'est la
surveillance l'écoutent l'aide auprès de
ces jeunes et c'est là que je rejoins
monsieur traoré qui va sans doute nous
en parler plus plus en détail c'est le
service le service militaire c'est
l'encadrement plus autoritaire au sein
des structures de la république ça oui
mais faire porter la responsabilité à un
parent qui est sans doute déjà démunies
celui qui fait bien son travail qui
essaye de le faire du mieux qu'ils
peuvent mais qui ne peut pas avoir un
contrôle absolu sur son enfant qui
devient un être humain indépendant libre
de penser est libre d'agir par lui même
je pense pas que ce soit la solution
on va recueillir des avis de
chroniqueurs et ensuite nos deux invités
vont répondre dans karim est ensuite
yann ouais moi je crois qu'il est un
sujet trop important pour qu'on se
raconte des histoires et qu'on réponde
par une forme de manichéisme
oui ou non faut sanctionner les parents
en pensant que de par cette réponse
positive ou négative on réglera le
problème c'est quand même le sujet qui
est plus complexe que ça d'abord on est
mineur quand on a moins de 18 ans est ce
qu'on doit se comporter de la même
manière à ce que la société de se
comporter de manière quand un gamin de
10 ans et dehors à 23h30 train de casser
une voiture pour voir et un autoradio et
est-ce qu'on doit se comporter de même
manière avec un gamin de 16 ans qui fait
mettre 90 et qui fait la loi chez lui je
pense que la réponse est non et que si
un gamin de 10 ans à 23h30 et ac est en
train de casser le véhicule pour vous un
autoradio la responsabilité parentale de
mon point de vue est totale on pourrait
sanctionner
elle est totale elle est totale et après
la société doit s'interroger dans la
sanction qu'elle doit apporter
on n'utilise pas assez de mon point de
vue le mode contraventionnelle moi je
considère aujourd'hui que plutôt que de
passer un stade des délits d'intiés qui
met à machine judiciaire en branle c'est
long c'est si on n'a pas de réponse
immédiate policiers municipaux
oui c'est impoli en fonction de
l'appréciation ramène un gamin de 10 ans
à 23h30 alors qu'il est en tant
qu'actionnaire je pense qu'on est en
droit de demander 35 euros donc aux
parents immédiatement et je pense qu'il
n'y a pas d'excusé dessus circonstances
atténuantes donc à un gamin de 10 ans
qui dort 23h30 et il n'y a pas de
questions de parents il est réparé en
mach un parent qui vient de 2,6 par an
qui vient de là je vais vous dire les
déterminismes sociaux est inique même de
quartier n'ont aucun sens l'immense
majorité des gamins des quartiers sont
respectueux des règles
l'immense majorité on a 80 % aujourd'hui
des actes de délinquance qui sont commis
par 5 % de jeunes multi 1000m et karim
coûtera 24 juin à finir mon raisonnement
vous composé de taper au portefeuille
des portefeuilles qui souvent sont
récusés moi je suis en train
dire qu'à un moment donné la
contrepartie que la société a porta
départ en difficulté ça implique des
responsabilités
dix ans c'est d'élever son enfant et on
trouve encore une fois qu'à aucune
circonstance atténuante à ce qu'un gamin
né cet agent a en revanche lorsqu'on à
la sphère de youri prenons la sphère qui
est qui et qui a fait l'actualité
un hachage à lynchage de gamins qui ont
entre 15 et 18 ans n'ont pas encore la
majorité et qui se retrouve à neuf dans
un acte de barbarie le plus total a
laissé pour mort un gamin qui à leur âge
ils sont neuf dessus je ne vois pas où
la responsabilité avantage je m'excuse
de vous le dire je pense qu'à 15 ans on
est responsable de ses actes et c'est le
jeune qui est concerné par la sanction
j'ai super mal fait en fait j'ai envie
de dire qu' il faut passer à la réponse
qu'on apporte
est ce que la prison aujourd'hui est une
bonne réponse pour un jeune de 15 ha non
donc je pense que quand on fait les
analyses sérieuses la réponse est non
je préférerais des centres d'éducation
renforcés avec l'idée de mettre en place
à la fois des essais militaires mais
aussi les membres de l'éducation
nationale faire en sorte que le gamin
soit douze mois donc réapprendre les
règles à vivre dans un cadre qu'elle
respecte avec des règles strictes et
derrière ressortir avec un diplôme qui
pourrait s est lui permettre de
s'épanouir dans la vie d'un gamin il
n'est pas perdu mais on ne peut pas
laisser l'impunité totale face à un acte
de délinquance ou de barbarie tel qu'on
l'a vu il faut sanctionner mais
l'échelle de la sanction doit être
gratuit quand on regarde à 10 ans quand
il a 16 ans et je termine juste en
disant que les familles monoparentales
faisons honneur aussi assez maman qui
élève les enfants tout seuls et dans
l'immense majorité les enfants sont
carrés il n'y a rien à dire
la maman des dehors elle est dedans elle
est au four et au moulin comme moi j'ai
eu deux grands mères qui ont été vers la
quarante huit enfants d'un côté trois
enfants de l'autre ya pas eu un cheveu
de kia bouger dans la famille parce que
c'était des femmes qui s'occupait de
leurs enfants qui travaillent à
l'extérieur et donc je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de caricaturer les gens des
quartiers les gens d'origines aussi les
gens de condition sociale que nous les
méga y en a partout
regardez le père social watch